eu vou considerar os meus alunos
nós estamos numa sala de aula e aí nessa
sala de aula onde eu me sinto bem mais à
vontade
se alguém me contestar o voto de castigo
vou contar uma historinha pra vocês como
vocês são meus alunos né
eu vou contar uma história de uma vida
uma vida simples de de uma menina que
nasceu na cidade do interior na serra
gaúcha são francisco de paula
naquele tempo não tinha escola só tinha
um grupo escolar não tinha livaria não
tinha biblioteca não tinha na valia dos
jornais que meu pai comprava e das
revistas de moda que a minha mãe
comprava também para fazer os vestidos
das clientes dela
aí quando eu terminei o curso elementar
como dizia naquela época o meu pai me
disse minha filha do tempo que continuar
estudando pra sermos independentes não
depender de ninguém
se depender de mim mesmo há sempre eu
vou te internar num colégio de freiras
eu fiquei muito entusiasmado sem saber o
que era aquilo
eu nunca tinha visto uma freada na minha
filha lá na minha terra não tinha freira
não tinha colegas de empresa nem nada né
quando eu cheguei no colégio foi o
colégio são josé sobre o ponto quando eu
cheguei no colégio e via aquelas pretas
assim manto preto a roupa marrom
aquele papo branco assim aquilo me deu
um impacto assim sabe eu me sentia
pensei que estava no céu ou no inferno
não sabia
mas fui me adaptando aos poucos né
e sempre com aquele receio das irmãs me
corrigindo isso aqui é muito feio isso
aqui não pode ser é pecado
olha o pensamento não pensa em coisas
feias era aquela coisa assim que eu não
estava acostumado com nada disso
bom mas aí lá no colégio são josé
fui me adaptando aos poucos vai chegar
às outras meninas então a gente vai se
acostumando e eu fui fazer o curso para
a preparação de para entrar no curso
complementar que era um curso de
professora naquela época a gente já sai
com o título aluna mestre
veja só de pomposo que ela ea gente
sentia muito importante né
bom aí terminei meu curso complementar
meus pais foram a minha formatura foi no
dia da formatura eles foram assistir e
lá pelas tantas a madri e mandou um
recado pro meu pai que era para ele
esperar esperar lá na sala de visita eu
já fiquei assustado de vih que será que
eu fiz meu deus a gente vivia sempre em
pânico
aí
aí eu sei que fomos pra sala de visita
né
lá pelas tantas aparece a madrugada uma
alemã atleta o nome dela sim imponente
com ele chegou nós sentamos ela
cumprimentou todo mundo aí ela disse eu
vim falar com o senhor o senhor levar
para porto alegre a sua filha para
continuar os estudos de pintura óleo
eu tinha feito curso de pintura olha lá
no colégio né
a minha professora de dezembro ela
elogiava muito meus desenhos até que um
dia ela me convidou pra ele visitar a
sala de audi e de pintura fui me
inscrevi por curiosidade que eu nunca
tinha feito nada com ódio era só lápis
de cor que eu conheci
aí no dia da formatura terá exposição
meus pais o olhar gostaram muito
vamos esperar a amada na sala de aula na
sala de visita
ela aconselhou meu pai me trazer para
porto alegre pra fazer estudar no
instituto de artes do instituto de belas
artes
bom nós fomos para são francisco passará
à história na paulo no novo e ele sempre
foi muito interessado em nos dar tudo
aí voltou a porto alegre para se
informar no instituto de belas artes
como é que se inscreve para colher o
exame precisa fazer aí eles deram
instruções todas indicaram a professora
que morava na frente já foi atravessou a
rua e fui lá falar com a professora
janela de uma listinha de livros e coisa
por fazer
o material já foi na na na livraria do
globo naquele tempo ainda existir
compram material em si foi pessoal
processo lembrou que o material aqui a
professora marcou para estudar papai eu
comecei a estudar não obedeceu e pisa
tudo o que a professora tinha marcadas
exercício
viemos para porto alegre eu e meu pai aí
imagine só uma menina em porto alegre
sozinho depois de um internato
[Música]
mas como eu fui
fui morar numa pensão que era um casal
tinha uma pensão eram amigos dos meus
pais já conhecidos por isso que me
trouxe fosse outra vantagem
aí eu fiquei mas também já me sentia
assim perdido que não conhecia ninguém
todo mundo desconhecido né meu a menina
muito tímida muito bobadilha muito
engenheiro e foi-nos comecei a fazer
meus estudos no instituto de belas artes
terminei meu curso graças a deus muito
bem e aí o que que eu ia fazer com
aquele diploma
meu pai o que eu vou fazer com esse
diploma não sei se na arte pra ninguém
eu sei fazer mas é assim vai para o
magistério
vai lá na secretaria de educação vai te
informar lhes fazia tudo assim era
particular e fazer tudo vai lá na
secretaria de educação e informar como é
que eu posso entrar lá ele foi
secretário informa
aí você olha é nós temos um concurso de
título
os documentos dela os cursos que ela tem
e ele é isso aí
aí ele me escreveu lá na secretaria
naquela época lá ela dava um curso de
preparação para o ensino da arte na
escola dos alunos para as crianças e
adolescentes
fui fazer o curso
saí muito bem teve direito até de
escolher as regras da 136 escolas pra
gente escolher em porto alegre só uma
escola para começar o meu estudo meu ver
o magistério
bom passeio muito bem né
comecei a trabalhar e nunca mais eu
pintei na minha vida
larguei tudo eu só pensava em funcionar
da aula da aula os alunos eram muito
desarrumado com os meus alunos
adorava o trabalho deles
as exposições na própria escola na sala
de aula e tudo isso ficava muito muito
contentes de ver os seus trabalhos
expostos
bom aí lá pelas tantas eu trabalhei 32
anos no magistério 32 anos
minha filha ficou agora está na hora de
largar tudo
agora vem ver o neto por aí pedir a
aposentadoria mesmo o mesmo dia já
pensou naquele momento já que a escola
que encaminhava todo recebia
aposentadoria na licença para ir embora
da escola e fiquei em casa esperando meu
neto no fim veio a meta
a bruna é essa que anda por aqui que
anda com bill e de agosto
ela é muito minha amiga muito querida eu
adoro meus netos tem três netos só eu
sou pobre e netos
bom aí nasceu minha meta não vou vir
fazer roupinhas comprar roupinhas é
aquela coisa você sabe muito bem quando
vem uma criança na casa da gente na
família
aí foi um belo dia meu marido faleceu já
estava doente e morreu
do meu lado dormindo ele sempre dizia
que queria morrer do medo
ele morreu como ele queria mesmo né
bom aí eu fiquei muito deprimida muito
chocada muito triste porque aquela perda
porque foi um marido maravilhoso e para
mim também
eu senti muito e eu vivia chorando e
clamando ele chegou em casa e mãe deixa
de chorar nem pensa em deixar de chorar
tu não dizer que enquanto se aposentar
se ia fazer o gol
coisa que gosta vai lá na livraria do
globo e convence material contra tela
comprar tinta contra isso comprar aquilo
e deixa de estar chorando que cuida nem
parece que uma mulher de uma mulher que
tem que chorar não é um homem
aí fui lá na livraria comprei um
material coisa levei para casa mas eu
não comecei logo eu tinha medo
eu pensava que que eu não ia saber mais
perguntar depois de 32 anos a não ser
mais o pintado não tem idéia pra nada
assim tem paciência do sabe isso é o dom
da pintura da arte
ninguém tira isso aí dentro de ti foi
deus que colocou dentro
agora só falta pôr para fora aí onde ele
saiu com a qual qualquer norma a minha
netinha que era pequenininha e eu
aproveitei voltou sozinho vou fazer vou
fazer arte
aí comecei a pintar mas fiz um pôr do
sol
a coisa mais linda do esporte nos
quadrinhos pequenos assim os dois do sol
aí eles chegaram na casa do meu filho
que eu fiz hoje foi lá olha mãe olha aí
tu disse que não sabia mas pintava
começou tá certo é isso aí vai
vá em frente pintar o que quiser vai
travar ou pintar vai ter muito aí eu
comecei a fazer pintura aqueles quatro
pontos acumulando lá dentro de casa e eu
não sabia mais onde botar pendurar um
belo dia eu fui no banco estava um
espaço de uma exposição na guarda cheia
agora vou vou me inscrever num formato
de uma moça que era responsável pela
inscrição
me inscrevi para tal da tecla e fiz a
primeira exposição um banco e aí começou
era noutro banco será que era livre teve
um ano que eu fiz sete exposições
lado pro outro do outro a banca na sala
de saulo que o mar quintana na
assembléia na câmara de vereadores em
vários lugares na ilha já tinha já era
também exposições assim grupos de tudo
eu vim group lá com umas colegas
refeitos sente mais segura para sair
correndo procurando nos locais mas eu
sentia assim não chegando uma época sem
que um ponto que eu já estava saturado
de pintura eu queria aprender alguma
coisa diferente um dia poder no jornal
assim xilogravuras
informações telefone tal ato na mesma
hora eu peguei o telefone liguei pra me
informar onde é que era o garoto era bem
pertinho da minha casa
no outro dia eu já fui da me inscrevi já
já pediu o material na lista de
materiais de coisa é procurar o material
a expor nesse material também uma escola
que ensina crianças de 8 a 80 fazer
xilogravuras e não parei mais
é um é um vício uma coisa que não tem
nada que supere a lusa
ae lá pelas tantas está fazendo chegou a
gravar um amigo só vão andar na lua
telha de contar com a tv nem sei onde é
nunca fui andando lá vão conhecer vão
falar com os professores um professor lá
que conheço
então fui lá era o professor cavar
conversamos e ele perguntou o que eu
faço eu faço pintura faz um estilo que
aprender a fazer gravura em metal the
guardian é muito pesado isso
eu achava que era assim uma coisa né
é difícil que não é muito fácil vai ver
como é bom vai lá e compra não sei que
mandou comprar uma tv nova para fazer
mas eu não tenho o material assim em
cobre e uma lâmina de cobre coisas assim
não isso aí a gente faz uma vaquinha os
alunos tão acostumado a fazer a máquina
pois o empate cada um fica com o seu
pedaço
aí fizemos isso comecei a fazer a
gravura em metal então era em duas
técnicas que eu fazia uma escola e outra
no cbr no no atelier livre
aí fiz por anos a fio adorando tudo
daquelas vamos pra mim é são sagrados ou
não um falto nunca aí o professor de
estilo saiu
a professora disse que ela morava em
novo hamburgo era muito longe perdi
atento elencou o dinheiro que tinha de
ônibus e ela tinha tv em casa vai
resolver num novo não direcionar mais lá
aí eu fiquei sem professora mas eu
continuava a não ser é esperando que é
seu professor e nunca vi
passaram se dois meses não vinha
professor da unb o professor de não vão
mais aparecer aqui eu vou lá pro plata é
livre
lá tem professor de destino tem
professores de metal é o mesmo professor
continuei fazendo ea gravura em metal
então um ano passado eu fui convidada
para fazer um cada um depoimento no
aniversário dele 80 anos parece do
prédio onde funciona o santander hoje
que ali naquele tempo eu fiz exposição
lá que era dançarina banco meridional
naquela época meu depoimento e e estou
fazendo estou participando do 1
uma exposição do na galeria mascate ali
na rua laurindo do porto alegre e agora
estou me preparando para fazer uma
exposição no fim do ano em novembro
no atelier por insistência do meu
professor há três anos que ele vem
impressionando mp funcionando e este ano
ele eu vou lá na secretaria vou te
escrever nem que não queira
eu brinco muito com ele ele é bem mais
gostoso você sabe que onde eu vou eu
sempre sou o vovô da turma no ateliê
livre também são todos jovens assim como
vocês eu adoro adoro ficar entre os 11
jogos a gente brinca trocar idéias e
troca trabalhos
o professor é muito brincalhão também me
sinto muito à vontade assim
brigo com ele às vezes né mas então
agora vou fazer tal disposição e
novembro
isso aí é que me dá a vida da gente da
energia à vontade de trabalhar de
vontade de viver
o intercâmbio entre eu e minha velhice
ea própria juventude de vocês
isso aí tem anima enquanto eu tiver as
minhas mãos firmes
eu vou continuar fazendo o meu trabalho
de gravura estilo glamour que deus
quiser
[Aplausos]